(gentle instrumental music)
We are in the western side
of the Lambayeque Valley
in the north coast of Peru.
This is an area
where, in the past,
many, many important
Pre-Columbian
societies developed,
particularly the Moche
and the Lambayeque.
This is an area that
is super-interesting
from many point
of views, ecology,
the creation of landscape,
the creation of culture.
And in the center of everything
is this complex of pyramids
called Chotuna-Chornancap.
Are we in a hurry?
Yes.
Damaged by water,
looting and encroachment
is the biggest threat
to archaeological sites
all around the world.
That's why we are here
in Chotuna looking
at an excavation,
helping people like
Carlos Wester do his work.
Archeologists have
always been looking
for better ways of
doing their work.
We're very opportunistic.
We are in the early
stages of using drones
for this type of work.
Finally we can fly
above our excavations
and take a picture
that reveals everything
that we have been
seeing from below.
(light instrumental music)
Within a day, we can have
all the pictures taken
and we can have
three-dimensional models.
And by the next day, I will
have a completely developed
assessment of what to do
to prevent damage
produced by water.
So, what one drone
can do in one hour
is equivalent of
what we could do it,
with traditional
methods, in three months.
Drones only fly.
They take pictures.
We don't have a
real confirmation
of what is below the ground,
and for that, we
need archaeology.
Archaeology is a
destructive process.
When we dig, we destroy,
so we have to be
extremely careful
to record everything
we find in the ground.
We are rushing to save sites
before they are destroyed.
And the truth of
the matter is that
they are destroyed
on a faster pace
than we can rescue the
information that they contain.
There are many
reasons for studying
and preserving the past.
We are only the
continuation of a process
that started a long time ago.
And many of the problems
that we have today
can only be solved
if we look back at
how we came to be
the way we are.